not only did Philadelphia play at home yesterday
so an easier commute but they played at 1:00 in
the afternoon they've been here waiting for the
New York aors probably watched the game in their
hotel room but they do play hard so you better be
prepared for their their effort off the face off
here's Ryan poock and it's into the glove of
Aron sends it around into the skates of Paul
Mary Kyle paulm dips his shoulder brings it to
the net and it's poke kicked Away by Aron then
pull loock off his Bat fot fired wide Ops in more
than 31 minutes last night in Ottawa a remarkable
amount of time on the ice as doson shot knock
down rebound was there Horvat couldn't grab it
in time and cikas tonight MC delorier unable to
get it out taken by go to the front it redirected
off of stall and forced erson to make a save
the last time they played right around this
point see if the Islanders can hold on to this
and keep playing that way that shot got through
Sook couldn't see it the rebound was underneath
him I don't know how it didn't hit Matt barzel
you'll see this it almost comes right through
him and that's the hardest thing for a goenda
was trying to get a piece of it himself set Sam
baluk up with it baluk twisted down to the ice by
Noah Kates it's Kates bringing it around throw to
the front tapped on goal and is saved from soken
ao's injury said there wasn't one to provide yet
we're still going and seeing doctors we do know it
is a long-term injury for Adam pelic he'll be
out at least talking to Paul moris and he was
raving about his defenseman and said a guy like
Mike Riley deserves to play more and just can't
find a way to get him in the lineup yeah the
biggest strength for him too guys is going to
be breaking the puck only as far as Walker carried
in it's Kates from the circle with a shot and the
safe from soken that rebound just sitting there
before it's Thompson who grabs it and sends it up
MCE for pel over to Anders Lee off to skate out
of the reach of his stick comes to the end wall
he collides with sealer but the puck was left
behind for Walker Walker ahead for Kates Kates
moves it to the wall pass to the front Ryan paling
drags and shoots off the shoulder of sokin three
in the last four including the game winner last
night in Ottawa that one off the high glass lton
centers it's knocked down by sokin and played
just past the net 11 goals for Travis concy in
the first 20 games of the year already got good as
this is battle four behind the net it's connecting
again pops out in front and kicked Away by soken
on the try from cier it fun for you to when you
watch a guy like that play and kill penalties
yeah but they I think they do it they do it
a little differently and uh and it not to make
it sound bful but I I was picked come on Anders
Lee musling it to the net nothing there I don't
know I love it B oh no you were hurt but you I I
may not have played shot from Walker in the the
rebound pushed wide by concy Forester popped up
and appears to be skating okay as engal drags
this Puck thrown to the net save made rebound
backhanded on goal by a diving Brock Nelson he's
averaging just under 25 2449 is his average on the
season Tipp it with a step on doson able to get
through and save by sokin he was able to keep his
upper body elevated just enough there's a nice
tip from frost and SRO another great stop and
then tip it as he drives through almost lifted
over soken as he used was very very he was very
strong against Dobson Tippets really impressed
me we'll reveal that later on yep and poster your
answers to # Cadillac trivia giveaway goj denied
then cekus a blast that was blocked horvat's pass
goes all the way through to the corner Thomson
up it's barzell instead on the back hand flip
to the front for Horvat and a glove stop by
Samuel Aron good save by the by the [Music]
goenda clean sheet of ice is exactly what you
want to be able to snap that puck around but
connect steals it away from Matt barel coming in
short-handed with a backand that hit the outside
of the post goer he can fly circling the Zone
sets up pulock power play over pulock moving in
sets up goer on the back hand and Aon made the
save on the back hand and nice play as go after
he makes the pass heads towards the net just
doesn't get a whole lot on you can kind of see
him shovel it towards the goalie Erikson that's
about as good as you could do on your backand
with a hard pass like that you mentioned it but
you'd like to get more on at the angle turns and
misfired got it again forced to the front cannot
get through POF tees it up Rolling Puck for Horvat
Sav by Aron one of his best in front of the net
but watch Ryan takes a little look it's rolling
as you mentioned Brendan and Horvat lets that
one go and good positioning again off the right
shoulder oh what an opportunity that was now
it's Tipp it the other way Pou the only one
back sanheim charging sanheim gets there sokin
made the save ties come right back and El Paso
needs to move over there Romano to Nelson Nelson
had it stripped conni back to his feet charging
in it's theok with the game saer no goals on
the board Here's horat To Win It shot it wide
oh another going to get another chance it looks
like barzel tried to sneak it in and Aron hugged
the post FL and it's off of stick and wide
picked up by Atkinson Cam Atkinson and tied
in a kick save by [Applause] soken B Horvat will
be the first shooter for the New York Islanders
against Samuel Aron the seconde NHL who made 24
saves to this point and he makes another here
here with a stick on Horvath again aggressive
move by Arison and Horvat used that same move
now that was the third time he scored the previous
two and you know you watch tapes and there it is
he's trying to go up high but a really good save
by Arison as he's out at the top of the crease
so if you can't see the crease Brendon you're
supposed to deep Cam Atkinson the first shooter
for the Philadelphia [Applause] Flyers and he went
to the backand and sokin slid with them aggressive
move too by soken sokin hasn't had a lot of
success on these shootouts but watch how far
out of the crease he is so his time is good and
nowhere to go the blocker right in place Oliver
walster will be the second shooter against
Samuel Aron in his first career shootout the
goenda knocked down by the glove hand maintained
his angle that's all about maintaining your angle
look at where his position is he's waiting he
knows he wants to go back short Side High Gober
backand which one does he go with he comes in wide
left the right-handed shooting barzel save by Aron
as he tried to go over the P oh he's made it look
easy I mean he has made it look very easy The
Islander Shooters haven't even come close honestly
barzel coming in not much of a fake and doesn't
get it up he's tried to go low over the pad Morgan
Frost has the first chance to win the game for
Philadelphia slows up coming wide left weaving
back it's soken stayed with him and gloved it now
when you go in that slow the goalie is not going
to have to move he can wait you all day let's see
what Palms can do we haven't seen a change of pace
yet everyone's come in at the same constant speed
that might be what it takes Arison seems like
his timing is on yeah very good and Paul mer
decides to go High glove or not he's got speed
here he comes Kyle paary couldn't finish the
backand as he got erson to bite never got the
shot [Applause] away here comes the youngster
Forester a right-hander see if he wants to go
High glove or the back end this looks like more
of a forehand move to me Tyson for scores and the
Flyers win it one nothing in the fourth round of
the shootout and Philadelphia snaps the Islanders
three-game winning streak beat Samuel Arison and
the only goal that beats aokin is this one the
second career shootout attemp for Tyson Forester